El vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias a
iTalki, más sobre esto en un momento.
Más de una década de infrainversión en
la industria de extracción de gas y petróleo,
junto a la invasión rusa de Ucrania han creado
la profunda crisis energética que hoy está
castigando duramente a muchas economías a
lo largo y ancho de todo el mundo. Una crisis
que, ahora, amenaza especialmente a la vieja
Europa.
Sin embargo, en esta crisis hay más protagonistas.
Y no, en esa ocasión no os vamos a hablar
de las energías renovables, ni tampoco de
la nuclear. Ni siquiera del Hidrógeno. Sino
de algo quizás mucho más importante a corto
y medio plazo para garantizar el suministro
energético entre los viejos clientes de la
Rusia de Putin:
Por supuesto me estoy refiriendo al gas natural
licuado o LNG por sus siglas en inglés.
Este es ya, uno de los grandes protagoonistas
de la actualidad geoconómica internacional.
El recurso clave que condicionará la economía
mundial durante los próximos años.
Pero antes de continuar, dejadme que os hable
de italki. ¿Sabías que España es el 2º
país en la Unión Europea con peor dominio
del inglés?
Y sí, ya, lo sé, siempre podemos tener la
tentación de utilizar la excusa de, que bueno,
que al fin y al cabo, con un idioma tan fuerte
y tan importante como es el español no es
tan imprescindible dominar una segunda lengua.
Pero, en serio, ¿realmente te lo crees?
¿No tendrá más sentido aprovechar la fortaleza
de ser nativo en español y sumarnos un segundo
idioma fuerte, como el inglés? De hecho,
y, ojo que esto es importante, aquí podemos
jugar, incluso, con ventaja: los hablantes
nativos de inglés no se caracterizan por
dominar más lenguas, de hecho solo un 20%
de los estudiantes de primaria y secundaria
en EEUU estudian un segundo idioma, frente
al 92% de los europeos. Vamos: que si lo jugamos
bien, podemos convertir nuestra debilidad
en toda una fortaleza.
Pues bien, justo aquí es donde entra iTalki.
Con iTalki podrás darle un empujón a tu
inglés con la ayuda de profesores nativos
certificados. Solo tienes que elegir el tipo
de clase que más se ajuste a tus necesidades:
conversación, pronunciación, negocios (por
ejemplo, para entrevistas de trabajo), preparación
de exámenes, … Y no hay suscripciones ni
nada parecido, pagas por cada clase, sin compromiso
alguno. Y como sé que os gustan los datos,
aquí va otro: se estima que 19 horas en iTalki
equivalen a 1 semestre universitario.
En definitiva, ponte las pilas y coge el toro
por los cuernos. Y ojo, no tiene por qué
ser inglés: tienes más de 150 idiomas donde
elegir. A lo mejor crees que te viene mejor
diferenciarte y lanzarte a por el coreano,
por el alemán, o el chino, ¡por ejemplo!
Yo personalmente llevo usándolo desde hace
4 años y sé que no os vais a arrepentir.
No esperes más, regístrate ya de forma gratuita
en iTalki con el link que te dejamos en la
descripción.
Y ahora sí, vayamos con el vídeo de hoy.
El gas natural licuado es básicamente gas
en estado líquido. Esto se consigue gracias
a un proceso llamado licuefacción en el que
el gas extraído se enfría hasta unos 160
grados bajo cero.
(De este modo, a 160 grados bajo cero el gas
se convierte en líquido, ocupando mucho menos
volumen. Aproximadamente hablamos de una relación
de 1 a 600. Es decir, que un determinado volumen
de gas natural licuado ocuparía 600 veces
más en estado gaseoso. Esto hace que se pueda
transportar en grandes barcos metaneros.
Y, claro, el transporte por vía marítima
permite que aquellos países que no tengan
conexiones por gasoductos con los productores
puedan importar grandes cantidades de gas,
incluso desde lugares muy distantes.)
Hasta ahora todo parecen ventajas, ¿verdad?
Y lo cierto es que las tiene.
En 1964 entró en servicio el primer barco
dedicado en exclusiva a la exportación de
LNG. Fue la puesta de marca de una tecnología
que en los últimos 20 años ha crecido vertiginosamente.
Hasta hoy se han completado más de 80.000
transportes de LNG en todo el mundo y ya son
más de 600 los buques activos que transportan
el gas desde los países productores como
Qatar hasta las calderas de los consumidores.
Desde Japón hasta España. Toda una revolución.
En 2021 los 3 mayores consumidores de LNG
fueron por este orden: China, Japón y Corea
del Sur. Fijaos.
Las ventajas están claras, tan sólo tenemos
que mirar a Japón y Corea del Sur. Dos islas
energéticas que gracias a esta tecnología
han podido acceder a un suministro abundante
y relativamente barato de gas natural.
Ahora bien, todo apunta a que la importancia
del gas natural licuado se va a disparar durante
los próximos años.
(Aproximadamente el 40% de todo el gas que
se consumía en Europa procedía directamente
por tuberías desde Rusia. Este gas llegaba
a raudales y a precios tan bajos que los países
europeos se volvieron enormemente dependientes…
Hasta ahora.
La guerra de Ucrania lo ha cambiado absolutamente
todo. Y no se trata sólo de la guerra. La
Rusia de Putin ha demostrado no ser un socio
confiable. Y eso en términos energéticos
lo cambia todo. Pase lo que pase ningún país
europeo estará dispuesto a volver a depender
tanto de Rusia.
El problema es que hasta ahora no se ha construido
la infraestructura necesaria para sustituir
a este país. Y es que claro, teniendo un
gas tan barato, ¿para qué invertir en costosas
infraestructuras de gas como por ejemplo las
plantas regasificadoras?)
Ojo, hubo excepciones. Hay quien vio el peligro
muy claro desde el principio, fijaos.
(Lituania se convierte en el primer Estado
miembro de la UE en abandonar el gas ruso
- Bloomberg)
(KN da luz verde a la decisión de adquirir
la FSRU Independence
El operador lituano de la terminal de LNG,
Klaipedos Nafta (KN), ha aprobado la decisión
de adquirir la FSRU Independence una vez que
termine el acuerdo de arrendamiento en 2024.
- Offshore Energy)
Este pequeño Estado báltico de menos de
3 millones de habitantes ha logrado en un
tiempo récord deshacerse completamente del
gas ruso. Lo ha conseguido gracias a que en
2014 puso en servicio la planta regasificadora
flotante Independence. Lo hizo, precisamente,
para, llegado el caso, poder prescindir de
Rusia.
Además esta infraestructura le está permitiendo
al país báltico exportar el LNG ya regasificado
a Letonia, Estonia y Finlandia. [Por cierto,
¿sabéis de dónde procede mayormente el
gas que opera esta planta? Exacto, de Estados
Unidos. Y, ojo, en un momento veremos que
este apunte es clave.
En cualquier caso, la pregunta que puede que
os estéis haciendo es… ¿Cómo demonios
es posible que un pequeño país como Lituania
apostase en 2014 por tener alternativas a
Rusia y así garantizar su seguridad energética,
mientras otros como Alemania no hicieron absolutamente
nada?
¿Quizás estos titulares tengan algo que
ver?
(Se sospecha que espías rusos se infiltraron
en el gobierno alemán, según un informe
El servicio de inteligencia nacional estaría
investigando a dos funcionarios que trabajan
en el campo del suministro de energía. - Politico)
Pero como os decimos, eso ahora ha cambiado.
La guerra de Ucrania, las sanciones, el chantaje
energético del Kremlin… Todo esto está
obligando a que Europa busque alternativas
a Rusia. Y como los vecinos que pueden suministrar
gas por tuberías como Argelia, Azerbaiyán
o, incluso, Israel, no alcanzan para sustituir
a Rusia, ahora en el viejo continente resuenan
3 siglas por todas las esquinas: L-N-G
Pero claro, para que Europa pueda comenzar
a utilizar LNG en grandes cantidades hacen
falta 4 cosas:
Primero, una producción de gas suficiente.
Segundo, plantas licuefactoras en origen.
Tercero, metaneros disponibles.
Y cuatro: plantas regasificadoras suficientes
en el destino.
Esta es, básicamente, la cadena del gas natural
licuado. Y como en el centro de Europa andan
muy escasos, en los próximos meses y años
es casi seguro que veremos grandes inversiones.
(La guerra en Ucrania pone de nuevo sobre
la mesa los planes para las terminales LNG
alemanas - Clean Energy Wire)
(La carrera de Europa por nueva infraestructura
de importación de LNG se acelera - Energy
Bulletin)
De momento y a pesar de todas las limitaciones
las importaciones de LNG están batiendo récords.
Por cierto, ¿sabéis cuál es el país europeo
con más infraestructuras de LNG? 3,2 1, exacto,
España. Os hemos hablado ya de ello en VisualPolitik.
Fijaos en este mapa. En él podemos ver la
red europea. Y cómo podéis comprobar España
es con mucha diferencia el país con más
regasificadoras operativas.
(España tiene ni más ni menos que el 27%
de toda la capacidad de regasificación de
Europa y más de un tercio de la capacidad
de almacenaje. En 2021 España usó algo menos
de un tercio de toda esta capacidad. Es decir,
que el excedente para poder suministrar a
Europa sería bastante grande. Sin embargo
hay un problema: España es una isla energética.
Solo hay un gasoducto que cruza a Francia
y su capacidad es muy limitada. Y para colmo
los franceses no quieren saber nada de esta
posibilidad.)
(El alemán Olaf Scholz propone un gasoducto
que una España y Portugal con Europa - Euroweekly
News)
(España dice que el gasoducto a Francia es
posible en 8 o 9 meses - Reuters)
(Francia frustra la mayor esperanza de Alemania
de reactivar su economía
Funcionarios españoles sugieren que París
teme una competencia a sus exportaciones de
hidrógeno. [...] París asegura que el plan
de Berlín es impráctico y estúpido. Al
ministerio francés le irrita que llevaría
muchos años completar solo la planificación
y otra documentación. - TFI Global)
Ya sabéis, cosas de Europa.
Ahora bien, un momento, porque en cualquier
caso con tener la infraestructura no basta.
Hacen falta también proveedores. Y actualmente
eso no resulta nada fácil. La industria está
trabajando prácticamente a su máxima capacidad,
y las nuevas inversiones tardarán algunos
años en poder suministrar más gas.
Sin embargo, se confía que un país puede
venir al rescate de Europa. Por supuesto cobrando
la correspondiente factura.
¿Adivináis de quién estamos hablando?
Pues… Atentos.
ESTADOS UNIDOS: ¿ÚLTIMA ESPERANZA DE EUROPA?)
En un pasado vídeo
os contamos cómo Catar se ha convertido en
uno de los grandes reyes de la exportación
de gas natural licuado. Con Australia y Estados
Unidos es una de las 3 grandes potencias de
LNG de todo el mundo.
Sin embargo, el país del golfo pérsico tiene
un problema. La inmensa mayoría del LNG qatarí
está ya sujeto a contratos de largo plazo,
especialmente con países asiáticos.
Esto significa que apenas tienen margen para
responder al repentino incremento de la demanda
en Europa.
Así que las importaciones de LNG qatarí
mediante compras puntuales, barco por barco
- lo que se conoce como mercado spot - pueden
ayudar… Pero marginalmente. A corto plazo
no será una alternativa viable.
Al menos hasta finales de 2025 cuando se espera
que entren en funcionamiento las primeras
fases de la enorme ampliación de producción
que está desarrollando el país árabe.
Y con Australia, pasa algo parecido. Además,
la distancia favorece que las ventas se dirijan
mayormente a otros países de Asia. Digamos
que la menor distancia hace que un barco pueda
hacer más viajes de ida y vuelta, lo que
incrementa las ventas de gas.
Sin embargo, la situación de Estados Unidos
es muy diferente.
En este caso su mercado spot tiene más margen.
Entre otras cosas porque la potencia norteamericana
tiene enormes, gigantescas, descomunales cantidades
de gas… Que hasta hace unos pocos años
no exportaba. Sin embargo ahora se han puesto
las pilas para poder hacerlo. El negocio promete
ser multimillonario.
Fijaos otra vez en el gráfico que veíamos
hace un momento. ¿Habéis visto cómo están
creciendo las exportaciones de Estados Unidos?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, justo aquí
está depositada la gran esperanza de Europa.
(Estados Unidos se ha convertido en el país
clave para que Europa pueda sustituir buena
parte del gas ruso en un plazo razonable de
tiempo. Por ejemplo, el objetivo que hoy tiene
la Unión Europea es que como muy tarde para
el 2027 los países miembros puedan prescindir
completamente del gas ruso.)
(EE.UU. se ha convertido en el mayor exportador
de LNG al canalizar el suministro a los consumidores
europeos a merced de Rusia - Markets Insider)
Ya lo veis, la industria norteamericana se
está abriendo paso a toda pastilla. Y Europa
se ha convertido en su cliente preferido.
Si en 2021 Estados Unidos exportó de media
el 29 por ciento de todo su LNG a Europa,
en los primeros tres meses de 2022 más del
60 por ciento del gas natural licuado americano
fue a parar al viejo continente.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es, ¿realmente tiene
tanto gas Estados Unidos? Pues… Lo cierto
es que sí.
Fijaos en este gráfico.
Lo que estáis viendo es la producción de
gas natural de Estados Unidos. Como veis,
la producción que se sitúa en máximos históricos
se ha disparado en los últimos 15 años gracias
a una tecnología que lo cambió todo: el
fracking.
De hecho, el gas de esquisto, que es como
se conoce al producido por fracking, supuso
en torno al 79% de todo el gas producido en
Estados Unidos en 2021.
Un enorme crecimiento en la producción de
gas que ha hecho que la producción supere
ampliamente al consumo, lo que ahora sí les
permite poder exportarlo en grandes cantidades.
Os lo hemos contado en pasados aquí en VisualPolitik,
la tecnología del fracking ha supuesto un
antes y un después. Ahora las reservas potenciales
de petróleo y de gas se han multiplicado.
Esta es una realidad que Estados Unidos está
aprovechando intensamente. Para finales de
esta década se espera que Estados Unidos
le exporte a Europa al menos un tercio de
todo el gas que el viejo continente le compraba
a Rusia.
Pero la oportunidad no es exclusivamente suya…
Entre otras cosas, porque como veis no es
suficiente. Incluso teniendo en cuenta las
nuevas capacidades de Qatar y de otros muchos
países, sustituir completamente las compras
a Rusia parece una misión imposible…. Salvo
quizás por una posibilidad que de momento
Europa sigue descartando:
¿A qué me refiero? Pues…Prestad mucha
atención al siguiente mapa. En él podéis
ver los resultados de un estudio de 2011 de
la Agencia de Información Energética de
Estados Unidos, que buscó recopilar gran
parte de las reservas de gas de esquisto estimadas
en el mundo.
(Además,un informe de la propia Comisión
Europea en 2017 evaluó 49 de las 81 formaciones
de esquisto estimadas en el viejo continente.
Según este informe Europa tendría como mínimo
90 billones, con b, de metros cúbicos de
gas de esquisto.
Esto, para que nos entendamos, sería suficiente
como para cubrir casi dos siglos del actual
consumo de Europa. Es evidente que con estos
datos es muy posible que si Europa se pusiera
las pilas, las nuevas explotaciones de gas
viables económicamente pudieran cubrir buena
parte de su consumo.)
Es decir, que la diferencia entre Estados
Unidos y Europa es, básicamente, que en la
potencia norteamericana han apostado por hacer
negocio con esta industria.
Pero, no nos desviemos. Porque, pese a todo,
esta posibilidad no parece estar en los planes
de Bruselas.
Como veis, Estados Unidos se está convirtiendo
en un actor de primerísimo nivel en el mercado
internacional del gas. Un nuevo negocio que
le reportará decenas y decenas de miles de
millones de dólares cada año.
Ahora bien, Europa tiene otro problema: no
es el único cliente que compite por este
tipo de gas. ¿Os habéis preguntado por qué
se ha incrementado de repente tanto el precio
del gas?
Pues…Atentos.
2(LA GUERRA DEL GAS)
La guerra en Ucrania y las sanciones europeas
al gas ruso no solo han disparado los precios
del gas, también han hecho temblar los propios
cimientos del mercado.
Y es que, veréis, los países, como Corea
del Sur o Japón, que más han apostado desde
hace años por el gas natural licuado lo hicieron
porque, hasta ahora, era una fuente de suministro
relativamente estable y poco volátil.
Un mercado fiable y predecible, con pocos
saltos en los precios, que aseguraba un suministro
seguro y constante.
Sin embargo, todo eso ahora ha saltado por
los aires. Ya no existe. En el momento en
el que preparamos este vídeo el mercado del
LNG es lo más parecido a un bazar que os
podéis imaginar.
Hablamos de un mercado en el que el mejor
postor se lo lleva todo. Y dada la escasez
que existe podríamos decir que cada dos por
tres vemos auténticas bofetadas.
Y es que veréis, aunque los contratos de
largo plazo se respetan, hay una parte de
la demanda que se cubría con el mercado spot,
es decir, comprando barco a barco. Y ahora
este mercado concreto está totalmente descontrolado.
De hecho, hay países de bajos recursos que
corren el riesgo de quedarse sin gas básicamente
por no poder pagarlo.
(Los compradores del sur de Asia de nuevo
marginados por los altos precios del LNG al
contado - Natural Gas Intelligence)
Por poneros un ejemplo de lo que esto supone,
no son pocos los casos de barcos que ya cargados
de LNG y navegando hacia Asia de repente se
dan la vuelta hacia Europa simple y llanamente
porque algún comprador está ofreciendo pagar
más. Esto ocurre sobre todo con los cargamentos
que proceden de Estados Unidos y Australia,
que se rigen por el conocido como sistema
free-on-board.
En este caso el intermediario que compra el
gas, es propietario de este recurso desde
el preciso momento en el que los barcos se
cargan. Así que durante el tiempo que tardan
en llegar a puerto siguen negociando en busca
de un mejor postor.
El caso es que esto ha desatado una enorme
guerra de pujas entre Europa y Asia.. Lo que
por supuesto ha contribuido a disparar los
precios.
(Si de media el pasado año 2021, el LNG de
Estados Unidos se vendió a entre 4 y 8 dólares
por millón de unidades térmicas británicas,
ahora el precio de los futuros se ha disparado
hasta los 60 e incluso 70 dólares.
Esto supone que en apenas un año el precio
se ha llegado a multiplicar por 15. Y no solo
eso, en total el LNG exportado a Europa durante
los primeros tres meses de 2022 se pagó a
una media de más de 30 dólares, es decir,
unas 7 veces más caro que un año antes.)
Y, es que obviamente, los países europeos,
y especialmente en aquellos donde hay inviernos
más fríos o industria más intensiva en
gas, están intentando a toda costa y a cualquier
precio rellenar sus reservas para el invierno.
Y eso ha hecho reventar el mercado.
Pero bien, ahora que ya sabemos el papel que
puede jugar Estados Unidos y también por
qué el precio del gas se ha vuelto loco,
la pregunta es para ti:
¿Realmente pensáis que Estados Unidos puede
ser una alternativa clara al gas ruso?
¿Lograrán los países europeos resistir
el frío invierno y la escasez de gas hasta
que la infraestructura de LNG esté completamente
lista?
¿Qué más alternativas existen?
Podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas en los
comentarios. Y ahora, si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a VisualPolitik si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.